Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new arrow footage
let's break it down we got Black Siren we got
Prometheus they tease more Kovar heavy flashbacks
in the even have some Donald Trump joke that
will be happening in the flashbacks that I'll
explain.
there is a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
yay! everything's back all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a flash
arrow DC related comment on this video winners
are always announced at the end of videos
be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
I love the tip from wild dog.
This is getting good.
So this is really the black siren trailer
with Prometheus.
There's also some Russia flashbacks stuff
that I'll address because the producers were
talking about Kovar Dolph Lundgren's character
how he's going to be huge in the back half
of the season so let's start with the black
siren stuff first.
So, so they're all questioning like you know
who are you and then there's the reveal cc
a couple different versions of Katie Cassidy
you see the first version that was from the
end of episode nine were she just like I've
been saying and then they all seem like they
believe that it's time travel some flashpoint
twist but then later they cut all the footage
of everything exploding or using the Canary
cried to blow up everything all over the place
you actually see her use it a couple different
times in the episode.
The other like really big WTF one is blowing
up the black canary statue.
So there's like an explosion coming from this
side of the screen.
But then you see the sonic scream coming from
the other side, so that just crazy should
happening wild dog is not lying is is deafly
getting good.
I was really happy when they kill the character
off.
But I understand how they sorted needed to
soft reboot that version of Laurel is because
they drug or through the mud, so much so there
was wasn't that many places left to take her
and she was in a metahuman, so they couldn't
do real black canary.
So there a lot of different ways that they
could use her going forward.
It just depends on which version they want
to go with in how they want to either redeem
or throw this character in the mud maker a
villain for the rest of the run 40 been picked
up for season six.
Social definitely be back for season six and
Katie Cassidy will be back to.
You have to remember that sometimes when she
comes back she plays Laurel and flashback
she plays different versions of the character
so I'm totally happy if they continue to do
it that way but haven't really said how many
more episodes this season she's going to be
in and what's can happen next season because
it she's not gonna be a series regular I really
just want to see her come back in their use
her for metahuman Black Canary stories even
if it's black siren just turned good.
So it just depends on how this all plays out,
but right now black siren is very much an
evil character.
The way they cut the text into the trailer.
The things you saw, it's all part of the deception
they cut that with Billy's death because this
is the black siren episode that plays into
the Prometheus are so in the way he set up
Oliver to kill Billy he's also setting up
this black siren twist.
So somehow he's connected, the black siren.
Either he broke her out of the pipeline prison
or there is some flashpoint stuff happening
here the producers were kind of vague on how
flashpoint would affect things they'll explain
it in the episode, so no worries and just.
There are very few ways for people to travel
between Earth's without the help of a flash
like you can only travel through those little
portals if you have somebody traveling at
superspeed without some crazy technology.
There's no way black siren could come back
from earth two so it seems like she's been
here.
This whole time.
But the Prometheus stuff know people still
want to believe that there's some other big
twist there obviously going to be dealing
with Talley all cool stuff in this episode
to that goes back to Russia.
So I'm wondering how Kovar works in the Talley
all cool Prometheus stuff because right now
the Talley all cool stuff seems completely
separate but they always try to weave all
the storylines together by the end of the
season so it all makes sense like you understand
what Talley all cool is trying to do what
shall be doing in present-day how that ties
in with Prometheus and what Kovar has to do
with that all along the same lines they did
talk about the flashbacks because this is
the last season of the flashbacks they have
a whole lot of Russian Kober like you see
him getting beat up in this basement down
here still be at least one episode that is
almost entirely set in Russia.
That's a Kovar episode.
I mean you have Dolph Lundgren of course you
going to give him his own episode the evening
tease that they were going to be making some
sort of Trump Kovar joke because supposedly
Trump gets a lot of money from Russia this
going to be this corrupt American businessman
millionaire meeting with Kovar in a big flashback
episode.
They were like make of that what you will
but they were there trying to imply that the
gonna be poking fun at Trump just a little
bit.
So when that happens all totally pointed out,
but typically they don't go after like real
life politicians because it kind of dates
that show is Obama was only president for
certain period of time so if they use them
on the show and somebody was watching this
and say like 10 years, and it would really
make sense.
So that's why marvel DC typically use fictional
presidents when they do movies and TV shows,
but it also tells you how they might use flashbacks
in future seasons.
So typically what they've done in the past
of his head this flashback storyline that
runs concurrently with the present day storyline
you typically get flashbacks in almost every
single episode but what it sounds like they're
doing in the future.
Is that they'll do flashbacks when they're
necessary to provide context like a really
big character from Oliver's past showed up.
They might do a big flashback to explain what
they did in the past how they met each other,
but the neck in a do it in every single episode,
so they can be a lot pickier about how they
use flashbacks, which I think is good because
sometimes the flashback storyline just drags
on, but the Russia stuff has been great so
far this season, you guys can let me know
though you know big black siren episode.
How do you want them to use the character
and Katie Cassidy going forward.
There's a number of comic book ways to explain
how they could do new black canary like the
other big thing is there's a new vigilante
character that's going to be joining the show
for at least a minor are kind and how big
a character she's gonna be, but there's a
lot of people that are wondering if she might
be the new black canary because the producers
like it's really hard to do a green arrow
show without a black canary.
So because the show's been picked up for season
six just make it seem like there will be some
form of black canary in that season whether
or not it's Katie Cassidy or somebody else.
We have no idea, but also don't forget the
Katie Cassidy will also guest star on legends
of tomorrow out this probably can be part
of Sara storyline, so it'll probably be Laurel
instead of being black siren.
They haven't fully explain how that's gonna
work the shows are all coming back next week.
So my schedule be a little bit different because
legends of tomorrow is can be on Tuesday nights.
So this is my tentative schedule right now
this might change a little bit, but this is
kind of what I'm expecting it to be between
Tuesday and Thursday at least until some other
shows are coming back later in the year.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner mine craft full.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video.
If you guys to know I'm alternating an injustice
giveaway with the flash ring giveaway that
will be like all the DC videos both arrow
and flash and anything else for the movies
to, so was can happen is they just confirmed
a miles morale us Spider-Man movie is gonna
be made by Sony like a theatrical big movie
so I'm going to try to get that video out
by later tonight we'll see if I can get 3
videos out today while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for the new flash
trailer and you can click here to rewatch
the injustice trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!